I would be remiss if I didn't bring up
this extraordinary development that's
been occurring recently between
President Trump and the media where he
basically has been very public about the
fact that he doesn't like the media he
doesn't like the media's portrayal of
what he's doing he uses the term fake
news a lot
is this an extremely difficult time to
be in your business you know it should
be you know no one likes to have their
certainly what they do disparaged and
you know we we take great pride in the
care we put on a broadcast every night
but in in many ways I find it kind of
liberating because somebody bad things
have been said now that we can just do
our jobs and take the hits you know no
one is in this we know that news isn't
always make you feel good I mean tonight
our gonna challenge your your worldview
but now it's the sense of what are they
gonna say about us or the opposition
they already have
yeah so I think all of us are feeling
this is a good time to be a journalist
really because we really focus on our
job holding people in power accountable
and I think that people that certainly
watch my broadcasts understand that you
know we we're very careful with how we
curate the day every day and we put a
lot of thought and a lot of care into it
and you know you just do what you got to
do the there's been so much attention
paid to if the president sends out to
tweet for example or there's you know
I've Uncas brand is promoted by
Kellyanne Conway there's so much talk
about that that some people think real
issues are being underreported is there
any issue right now that you think is
being underreported because everyone's
distracted by the noise well I mean I
think that the the Russian hacking story
I think when that came out it was a huge
story I think it is still a huge story
unfortunately we're too close to the
election we can't separate it I wish for
a moment we could say forget there's a
Donald Trump forget there was a Hillary
Clinton let's just look at this what
happened here I still think that's an
incredibly important story that probably
because the political environment
discuss because it ends up being a
discussion about legitimacy and these
other guys right it's too loaded right
now but it does feel like at some point
the
needs to be an understanding of how much
of an influence did Russian hackers have
on our election if at all we need to
know yeah and I and I just think that
right now you know we don't want to be
talking about a lot of these things
right you know we don't want to have to
be making corrections and talk about
fall so it's in this we want to talk
about issues yeah but there are you know
there's a lot of things flying at us a
lot of us thought that after January
20th life would slow down of course last
year you know we had the Olympics we had
two political conventions I moderated
two debates we had an election and
January 20th we thought the world was
slow down not happening
yeah every day something else
you